[Music]
i hung out with the team to find out how
they're helping us all stay prepared
this holiday season check it out
[Music]
we are celebrating the holidays and
christmas at lavonita merry christmas
happy holidays everyone thank you and of
course you guys always know how to
celebrate conveniently
creatively let's talk about botanas
first so botanas are
amazing appetizers and we have them all
here for you we have from veggie trade
so fruit trays are all christmas
oriented we have wonderful ideas
frozen desserts if you want some
appetizers and you're on the go you can
get those as well
and i need to talk about this because
these two are just so beautiful
they are one of my favorites and this
year you can pre-order them for the
holiday season from la monita number
seven in henderson
called to get yours those are amazing
can i just take that one home
and then of course dessert that's a huge
part of the holidays and i think
we have cake we love sweets and we love
cakes i love anita get you can also
pre-order yours for the holiday that is
a beautiful one i thought it was a
decoration when i came in
very sweet and it's a natural cake wow
and then of course
you know traditional cakes but something
unique as well
yes tamales sweet tamales but not the
regular sweet tamales this year we have
strawberry and pineapple flavored
tamales
only for this holiday i'm gonna try this
because i've only had sweet corn tamales
so i need to try this and while i do
that
talk about drinks yes because you gotta
have a drink with your tamales so our
most famous one is of course the
champurrado which is uh you know kind of
like a hot cocoa with some flour
in there and then our beautiful hot
punch which it looks very hard to make
however
we make it easy for you you can get it
in the can already
take it home boil it and put some
cinnamon sticks in there
and our famous mexican hot chocolate
i'm still eating but i'm listening okay
yes and this year we actually
have an awesome holiday drink it's
called the sparkling
um the sparkling christmas punch it's so
good yes it's awesome and it has
moscato which is actually on special uh
for 8.99
at the store and we have some cinnamon
sticks
and it has some clovers on them and some
lemon juice
it's easy to make but it's also
beautiful this is super easy
really easy small gathering for the
holidays and it also has
i love the martinelli's and the kids can
have it too for a doll and kit which is
a cider
so cheers to you to you and la bonita
for the holidays and lastly here what
else do you guys do
for the holidays around town so we have
i am so excited about this so
you can go to the glittering lights and
purchase your tickets here at la bonita
which
is actually considered 50 off and you
get four donuts and coffee
okay i'm cold i'm getting my tickets and
glittering lights here thank you so much
so exciting
happy holidays from bbc cheers safe and
happy holidays all right there are seven
la bonito supermarkets in the vegas
valley click on bonitamarkets.com
to find the location nearest to you las
vegas now we'll be right back